oui je je m'étonne si pour la gauche la
capitalisation c'est l'abomination des
abominations alors pourquoi chers
collègues vous n'avez pas déposé des
amendements de suppression pour les deux
régimes individuels et collectifs de
capitalisation pour la fonction publique
nous croyons nous en la retraite par la
répartition parce qu'elle a sur un lien
générationnel et c'est parce que nous
voulons sauver cette retraite par
répartition que nous voulons voter après
l'avoir modifié cette réforme simplement
certes cherpia ou juliasses on peut pas
prévoir l'économie de demain mais on
peut prévoir la démographie et on sait
très très bien qu'a réjibrait participe
à paraît partition c'est un régime où la
clé c'est la démographie donc nous
voulons simplement réfléchir étudier et
je pense qu'on pourrait étudier un
système d'une fusée à trois étages le
premier étage c'est le socle c'est la
répartition c'est le lien
intergénérationnel le second étage le
deuxième étage
c'est les complémentaires gérés par les
partenaires sociaux c'est d'ailleurs la
retraite à point ou en cotise en partie
pour sa propre attaque en partie et
l'autre étage de la fusée ce serait un
étage par capitalisation la
capitalisation certes pose deux
problèmes le problème c'est que ce doit
être une capitalisation collective où on
ne disent pas les riches pourront faire
les modestes pourront pas faire donc il
faut un système collectif et solidaire
le deuxième point c'est la transition
c'est la raison pour laquelle on demande
à réfléchir à ce système de demain c'est
absolument fondamental et par ailleurs
par ailleurs si comme vous comme nous
nous sommes attachés à ce que demain en
France il puisse y avoir des fonds
souverains pour que nos centres de
décision ne partent pas si nous voulons
demain en France que nous ayons de
l'argent des Français pour qu'on puisse
investir précisément dans la transition
énergétique la transition écologique il
y aura pas d'autres moyens c'est la
souveraineté financière c'est la
souveraineté industrielle c'est là qui
est l'enjeu et on peut le faire sans
détricoter notre système monsieur
Lheureux
[Musique]